i had to i had to put my
uh my vest on because um the heat is
controlled by
my kitchen thermostat and so when the
sun
shines in in the kitchen it warms it up
out there but it doesn't do a lot for
this room so
if i look like i'm shivering
occasionally i am
okay um we'll uh
we'll come back to um
our session this afternoon
and um we're going to be talking
about section 148 which is
on page 65
so i see that
matthew has joined us again
and i believe that uh he wanted to
say a few words about this kind of a
overview for us and then we'll proceed
from there
and i understand someone will be joining
us from
the attorney general's office as well
and uh mickey is colonel quinn or
commissioner quinn going to join us he
is available and on the call
if you would like him to participate too
yeah bring just bring him up if you
would
okay i and we
the person from the ag's office
no he he's here oh he is yeah bring him
okay uh matt if you would like to
start out with an overview and then
we'll
go forward absolutely thank you madam
carolyn
good to see everyone uh once again today
um i'm actually going to have the
committee start
uh on page 64.
um because i think that'll help explain
um
what you then see on page 65.
um so this conversation
uh is a continuation of the lee act
commission that
was brought together by the governor
last year
and out of that report were 48 unanimous
recommendations that
some move forward through executive
order others were
advanced to rule and this is one of
those recommendations that would require
legislation
so what you see here on page 64
and i'm looking at line 13
which establishes a study commission
to review the best way for this
independent statewide entity to
take shape so you see that there are
in lines 20 to 23 what the makeup of
that commission would look like
and then the remainder of this page
articulates the duties that this study
commission would have
to bring forward a recommendation for
additional legislation next year
that if this commission does come to a
favorable recommendation
for this office and there's an
agreed-upon structure
you then see on page 65 the
appropriation
to this yet to be created entity
in the second year of the biennium only
so what we've done we've already
allocated the funding
to be available should this study
commission come to a favorable
recommendation and recommend
implementation
next year that funding is already there
and we were trying to be proactive and
think ahead to make sure that commission
had broad flexibility to to do their
work and
figure out the best path forward
that's kind of my overview of the
sections i'm happy to turn it over
to the department of justice and i see
matthew broadhead is here as well
if the committee has questions on more
of the details or more of the the
ongoing conversations
are relative to lee act okay
okay attorney broadhead would you like
happy to thank you madam chair so my
name is matt broadhead
um i am the bureau chief for the
transportation and construction bureau
and in that capacity in the civil chief
civil
council to the department of safety um
the leak commission was established in
june of 2020
it pulled together stakeholders from law
enforcement from
various community groups um and
stakeholders representing civil
uh liberties uni uh rights groups and
um just various stakeholders they came
to a really a remarkable
consensus on this um and this was
recommendation number 16
which is a centerpiece of their
recommendations
um it creates a independent oversight
or the recommendation creates an
independent um
body state agency that oversees
complaints of law enforcement misconduct
and since the commission
issued its recommendations back in
august
we had a various group of lawyers from
that represented law enforcement and
also the from the eclu and the public
defender's office
we had been working on legislation many
of the recommendations that we worked on
are in are currently in
sv 96 um but this one
uh we were not we were very close on
uh draft legislation that had consensus
but they were still
by the time the filing deadline came um
we still were um
at a kind of a uh a point where
we didn't quite have consensus um so a
study committee
or commission that that's in hb2
would really bring our work product that
is
existing to the finish line it's
envisioned that
that tight deadline that's in hb2 for
the commission
that between when we when we convene
in um if all goes well in within
july or august that we'd be able to get
to the finish line by that november date
that's in there
um i have uh an 11 page draft
most of the language has been
agreed upon the sticking points where we
really need legislative input on of
course uh
is on how to treat the public records
um you know what records are public what
records are not public are the hearings
public are they not public
and so the idea is to pull these
stakeholders back together with
with legislators and try to get this
thing like i said across the finish line
so
um that's that's kind of an overview i'm
happy to take any questions where
representative could you hold off just a
second and uh
commissioner quinn do you have anything
you want to add to that
no other than i agree with everything
attorney broadhead said i i was on the
commission so
we met for 26 weeks 26 different
occasions and as you um look at the leak
book
recommendation number 16 sections a
through i is pretty much a um
the end work product of a um
very uh diverse group that made this
recommendation
and i think it's very important and i
agree with matt you know
he's done a lot of work here and he's
trying to just
thread the needle and get it done
representative heath oh thank you um
this is a subject i really
know absolutely nothing about i've read
the billiard
recommendations and how i know it's been
controversial
i just because i read about in the
newspapers how is the process
when complaints come in how are they
there currently is no uh centralized
oversight that was part of the basis for
the
recommendation to create an independent
office currently
um you know on one side of the ledger
people were complaining that
when you have a complaint about law
enforcement misconduct you file it with
the agency that oversees the officer
and that creates an internal tension
and it there's many of those records
discipline records
are not public records so the public
really just goes into a vacuum
um that's you know one side of the aisle
on the other side law enforcement
agencies they have a they have a really
unique
role in society and that their their
authority
is unlike any other
area of employment and
so to create a standardized process by
which
these are overseeing is really palatable
and from
law enforcement they really want that
standard standardization so
um uh you know that there was room there
for
um law enforcement and uh you know
various stakeholders to get to an
agreement
you'll see that there are various states
that after the incident with george
floyd
many states adopted or moved
to adopt similar oversight agencies
massachusetts i think being the latest
uh that just went into effect
thank you so um if i may madam cheer
yes go ahead so this is uh the lorry
list i'm presuming
that we're talking about or is that
another debate about what to do with the
lorry list
those are it's connected um but this is
not the lorry list what this is designed
to do
is to replace the lorry list um there is
uh
another bill that we've worked on and do
have consensus on
um that addresses the current lorry list
or the
the the ees the exculpatory evidence
schedule um as it's known now
so we will um be
uh planning to offer a bill
um this session on the ees
um and um
for going forward this is designed to
replace the ees
thank you representative murray you have
a question
thank you madam chair um what is the
money going to be used for
is this to staff the entity um what
expenses are you expecting here for half
a million
yes thank you representative murray and
this is page 132
of the budget book um
we put together a very
high level sketch of what an agency
would require for staffing we worked
with the department of administrative
services to
identify some of those job titles the
appropriate compensation for those
ultimately all of that is contingent on
the study commission's recommendation
and what that ultimately looks like but
we did want to make sure we had adequate
funding
for what one hypothetical agency might
look like and we feel that this is in
the relative
size and scope of what this entity would
need
but again all of it contingent on what
the study commission would report back
on
so if i might follow up on that
um
this money would not be required
until next year is that correct
that's correct and you'll notice there's
no appropriation in fy22
okay uh representative so
oops let me let me drop back a bit
so the the 517
000 is for starting in 23.
okay thank you uh representative petrie
yeah thank you madam chair how extensive
is the lorry list in new hampshire
um there i i don't know how to answer
that
um there are um i think it's been
publicly disclosed there
there are 220 uh five officers on the
list currently
um and give or take a few um
it's currently sub the subject of of
several lawsuits in the sense that
some officers challenge their placement
and also there is a
seeks to make the the list public
um and that went up to the supreme court
and now it's still pending back down on
remand and superior court
um so the the
it that those are the facts related to
it i i don't know
i can't comment or characterize on how
extensive it is or
to the um you know comparable to other
states
uh with a similar population whether or
not that's
more or less than other states i don't
thank you um i uh sprott had i i guess
or
or uh mr malaya i i guess uh my question
is is
uh for either of you and the thing i
mean i
i think that the idea of establishing
something
as i understand it at the end the what
is envisioned is something similar to
the judicial conduct committee
applying to police officers um
but one of the things that that can and
i think generally that's a that's a very
good idea
um the caveat i have is i wonder
um if if how this is intended to apply
very sort of minor um
infractions by a police officer that
nonetheless
uh i suppose theoretically could be a
could be the subject of a loyalist and
let me just give an example a
hypothetical example suppose that
a a police officer is accused of
you know taking too long a lunch break
so it's you know the the the chief of
police or the captain or whatever says
you know
wait a minute you uh you're only
supposed to have 20 minutes or a half an
hour for lunch you uh
you you know you you were out you were
off we couldn't get you on the radio for
for 45 minutes so um what's going on
and the officer offers some kind of an
explanation
which now the who you know the
supervisor has to decide do i believe
that or not and suppose the supervisor
says i don't believe it
so now you know
at least at least arguably the the
police officer has been
has been found to have lied
so you know does that go to the
does that get on the uh the lorry list
and does that go to the uh
to this commission for being to be
resolved because i i
if that's true i suspect that there are
a lot of
those kinds of things you know maybe not
not the example i particularly made up
but those kind of really minor
sort of personnel things that happen a
lot
not only in law enforcement but in every
other industry
yeah i'm happy to take that matt i see
you're you're unmuted
do you want to go first the only thing
that i would say is
those types of decisions would be within
the realm of what the study commission
uh would look to uh sort out and
i guess matt at that point i turned it
over to you to speak to the details of
the current structure versus what
might have already been agreed to
previously yeah this um
so there are two things that i'll
address that and
it's a very good point uh representative
so the first thing is that that's what
this agency is trying to address
is that what might be misconduct in one
police jurisdiction
is not misconduct in another police
jurisdiction and
so those minor you know um
you know some would call them white lies
right um that could land you on the list
in one police department but maybe not
in another department
um and so what this would create would
be this agency would create
a uniform standard to treat things like
that and i will say
that the definition that we have
currently agreed on
for this type of claim is that conduct
that would negatively reflect on the
officer's trustworthiness or
credibility which is the constitutional
standard
and then it lists specific instances
including a lie
during a civil administrative or
criminal proceeding in a police report
or in an internal investigation
so there are kind of discrete
um i think uh tangible standards that
this
study commission would be analyzing and
and i think they would run through those
scenarios of what
should be um you know misconduct under
under the statute that we're creating um
representative quinn you have a comment
yes i just wanted to add to what matt
said to
to representative lin if um
section d in that um
recommendation in lee act we we asked to
define
statewide universal definition regarding
what constitutes misconduct and to your
point sir
you know a police department has an
internal affairs department
um uh you know officer says
uh i backed into a delineate a post i'm
sorry
um it's uh investigated it's it's solved
the officer gets uh
you know some you know um minor
counseling that doesn't go to this
committee
once we define integrity because to your
point sir there are a lot of mistakes
that are made there are a lot of things
that
get resolved but it's the most serious
or egregious conduct
or as matt said that goes to the
integrity
of what would be you know exculpatory in
trial so there are a lot of things that
take place that would never get
forwarded but that's why we had a lot of
conversation on this in lee act and we
said we have to define
to matt's point what is misconduct so
once we get that definition then
those types of cases to your point
something minor
if the person didn't um tell the truth
could be um an integrity issue and could
be
forwarded up so so the definition is
really really important but to your
point
there's so much that takes place that
are mistakes you know you know people
make mistakes they they will get
counseled they will you know it will go
in their file
but it might not rise to that level that
matt's
gonna hopefully get defined
i think you're muted uh representative
humburger
aaron we can't hear you okay how's that
yeah
there we go i obviously
hit the wrong thing as i was doing this
so i i apologize for my
uh lack of zoom experience
so uh representative murray you have a
ques
you have a question yeah thank you madam
chair is there a subjective element to
this because i think you know you're
looking at infractions
um something that say an officer says to
me might just roll off my back
um said to someone else might put them
over the edge
so is there a subjective element and how
do you deal with that or
you mean subjective in terms of the
definition of misconduct
yeah um you know suppose you you know as
i said you could say something to me and
it'll just roll off my back i should go
ha ha
you could say the same thing to someone
else and they want to sue you for
defamation or something yep yeah no it's
a good point and actually it's a key
um thing that we hear from our
law enforcement constituents on
our legislative working group and we
have worked really hard to um
you can't eliminate all subjectivity but
to really
uh focus the terms so that it
it reduces significantly the
subjectivity and
that was one um i think back in december
we had some meetings
uh maybe even in january on it but we
worked
really hard with the folks from the aclu
and uh with the chief habeki from hollis
dan conley who's an attorney prosecutor
and also a
member of law enforcement from goffstown
um as well as
representatives the lawyers for for uh
two of the biggest police unions in the
state
um and we work really hard to remove as
much subjectivity as possible so that
officers when they're on the ground they
know what
is or is not misconduct
you know representative murray if i
could just add to what matt said
and the reason i think this is so
important and uh representative lin can
can understand this based on his prior
um
career is that if if
if a head of an agency deems that he or
she believes that the officer
was not truthful that could essentially
end a career could end employment
so to that you know we thought that this
offered what was neutral independent
and an opportunity for the officer to
you know go in and say no this is you
know because at some point it's
if you might not believe that someone's
being truthful but
is it more probable than not i mean do
you have you know
is the proof knowing how high the stakes
are and then this offers an appeal
to the supreme court so knowing the
stakes are so high you know and i'll and
i'll let
matt um weigh in if he wants we just
want to make sure we get it right
and because a lot of times you know
there might not be that
concrete you know evidence or video
or so but it again the integrity is
everything and we thought that this
would be
you know offer more due process for
the men and women in law enforcement
yes he did yeah it made sense to me so
um
if i can understand it everything's
going well
that's my lawyer that's my lawyer so i
always go to matt
yeah yeah representative heath you have
a question
thank you ma'am chair um so then
what this means is we're going from no
system
no systematized process
to deal with these complaints
to a process that is organized
and has accountability and the
funds that are attached to what attached
to it will help
in the process of developing that
infrastructure
for which the commission would work um
i um i guess that's my question am i
getting this right
and if so i think this is a just a
very positive move for our state to make
because it seemed
so subjective previously um
but there just didn't seem to be a
process based on what i just heard
so um but will the funding
be used to bring consultants to help
design this
so the only thing that i would clarify
representative heath would be the
timeline
so we stand here march 15th by march
this budget hopefully will become
effective july 1st
i think that's everyone's hope um from
there this
ended this commission is established
they have until this november
to complete their work bring legislation
for 2022's
legislative session to to formally
outline what this entity would do and
then the funding piece only begins
in fiscal year 2023 once this entity
assuming it does move forward is stood
up
and the dollars would fund the staff and
their operational requirements so
no money tied to the study commission
for consultants or anything of that
nature
at least specifically at hb2 i don't
know if there are provisions
in other bills that might do something
like that but these dollars would be
once this is stood up and
operationalized
mr skipper did you have something you
yes please madam chair certainly go
ahead
thank you madam chair uh committee
members
uh for the record my name is john skipa
i'm the director of police standards and
training here in new hampshire
and um i just wanted to speak very
quickly to uh
madame heath's question
a little bit earlier i do think it's
important to
to let everybody know that you know
presently there is a system in place
it was determined that the system that's
in place to address these
kinds of events is not standardized
throughout the state
but in fact it is something that police
standards and training handles right now
we are the regulatory body for a
certification of police officers
and we do operate as an executive
stand-alone branch of government
and we do have statutory authority to
address these concerns
the problem that was highlighted during
the leak
commission was that there was no
really robust resources for us to do
this in the first instance and secondly
uh our rules lacked a lot of things that
commissioner quinn just spoke about and
attorney broadhead just spoke about to
include
a universal definition of
what would constitute misconduct and
a statewide universal way to accept
complaints
and then finally the
the notion of building in transparency
and and uh the public availability
uh for these types of hearings uh that
we already hold
so uh i i didn't want anybody on the on
this
uh committee to think that there is
nothing in place right now
uh in the first instance and secondly
uh i i look forward to working with uh
whatever uh subcommittee has put
together to
to address this i was not at the uh
the table during this last round of
discussions
uh that attorney broadhead was was uh
leading
and i do think that uh that would be
something that would need to happen
just so that we're we're making sure
that we're
representative lynn you have a question
yes uh thank you um and it's really
it's really more of a sort of a
two things that i that i hope this
commission will
will uh will will think about and or
uh that that it doesn't become a problem
and
i guess the first one is the issue and i
and i
say this because this has been something
that has been
um sort of a uh uh
things that lawyers and judges have
grumbled about in their in their own
disciplinary system
and that is that as as you uh you may
know matt
um under the uh both really into under
the judicial conduct system and under
the uh
the uh bar uh
regulatory thing it can it can often be
the case
that um uh
the lawyer at the end or the judge at
the end of the whole process
is required to pay the costs of the
prosecution
uh of the of the lawyer or the judge
and that may be entirely appropriate for
lawyers
and judges i think it would be
making the kind of money that lawyers
and judges are making and i think it
would be
it would be really unfair if law
enforcement officers
who went through this process at the end
of it were required to pay the costs of
of that and then the second thing and i
i
this may be something that's obvious and
maybe you've dealt with it already but
i assume that this
that whatever is proposed in terms of
how this commission will operate
eventually it will not in any way
interfere with law
the supe with law enforcement
supervision being able to take whatever
disciplinary action
they want to take in other words the
only thing that this commission would
deal with is
what what goes into this list uh whether
the
an officer gets fired or suspended or
nothing at all happens will be
entirely up to whoever's in charge of
the agency i assume and nothing
right i could take that um so the on the
issue of costs
um that we're very mindful of law
enforcement
because of their unique role and you
know i certainly i defend
uh state troopers uh when they're
accused of
misconduct in civil litigation um
and so from one incident we're mindful
of
a police officer may face a disciplinary
hearing they may face
a police standards and training hearing
they may face
a misconduct hearing under this uh
proposed statute and then a litigation
you know some civil litigation so
for defending for um things
simultaneously in some cases maybe it
does raise costs
concerns and so we've designed this
process to
be as minimal cost as possible and we
don't
we never considered having a cost
payment provision in terms of
um uh having to to force them
as a result of this to have to pay
that's not
in our proposed bill um and it never was
um
and i just forgot the second thing as i
was answering that
what was the second question that this
that nothing
that this commission would deal only
with
the issue of of whether something stays
on an officer's record or not it would
have no
it would in no way interfere with uh the
supervision of a police officer
the chief or whatever deciding that you
know the officer whatever the discipline
would be
correct yes this is uh the only issue
before this
commission would be whether or not there
was a finding a sustained finding of
misconduct
um there is no disciplinary authority
there is no
authority over the
law enforcement certification that's
governed by a separate process
this is uh for transparency purposes
uh and uh it has members of the public
that
sit on the commission so non-law
enforcement members
are take part in in the decision um so
it is a different standard than
police standards and training it is it
serves a different purpose
um like i said to replace the lorry list
um eventually
uh and to create accountability
thank you if i could
applicable yeah only going to be
working until such time as you decide
whatever
you decide for legislation is that
correct
matt did you want to take that one or
i'm happy to answer it but
i i'm sorry uh as far as when this
commission
would complete its work yeah so the
commission would only exist
and the commission has a sole purpose to
bring legislation to codify what the
duties would be
um the commission wouldn't uh exist in
perpetuity once
their recommendations brought forward
and then
assuming the legislature were to enact
those recommendations to create this
entity
that entity would begin operation in the
second year the biennium
and thereon
i have to think about that a minute um
in this so the the legislation
effective on passage
because if it comes in
november well you know november or
december depending on whether it goes to
by the time it gets through both of the
bodies
that we're looking at we're going to be
um in june
of 22
and so it would be
effective 30 june of 22. is that
am i interpreting that correctly
i would say representative it could not
take effect
prior to july 1st of 22
because the funding is only there in
that year
um okay this is also the commission
would have to work out and
next year's legislature could either
appropriate additional money if they
wanted to start sooner
um or they could you know push it past
july 1st right and that money would just
lapse
but i think those are all questions that
are best answered not
as part of this conversation with hb2
but rather
next session after this commission some
work
okay representative porter you have a
question i'm sorry that
uh i stepped in there okay madam chair
um thank you for letting me ask my
question um
again i i'm not familiar at all with the
lorry list or how
law enforcement officers are disciplined
or
whatever but um if there's a an officer
who
has serious misconduct and
ends up on the lorry list do other
jurisdictions looking to hire do they
know currently that this person
is on the lorry list or is that
confidential
at this point and if this once this is
this new entity is established will then
a jurisdiction have access to the list
of people who have serious
sure under our police standards and
training rule there's a background check
that's conducted for
every new hire and part of that is
review of discipline
so they'd be aware of it if it was
sustained discipline that's the only
thing that lands somebody on the lorry
list so
they wouldn't even need to go to the
lorry list to get that information
although um if if they've had dealings
in the past through cases or
or whatnot um you know they the
certainly they could
they could have access to it law
enforcement
and and prosecutors have access for the
okay
uh does anyone have
any opposition to adding
police standards and training to this um
uh represent the one thing that i would
just check on
is i know currently um
i just want to make sure that the
structure of the commission is
is balanced appropriately so right now
the membership
is the attorney general or designate
one member of the house one senator and
four members of the leak commission that
was established by executive order
so to the point that we start
identifying
additional members or members that might
be a subset of that react commission
would just want to make sure that we
maybe either
offset that or delineate others um
but i i i don't know if matt or either
of the agencies that are on have any
um i don't have any thoughts other than
um uh john weren't you a member of the
commission
uh yes i was so um certainly in that
capacity he'd be eligible to be
appointed
uh you know to that commission as
written
okay so the the four additional members
the um police standards and training was
there and who is
going to actually appoint
uh as written the uh
those four members i believe would be
appointed by
the commission that i i
i would have to check on that and report
back to uh madam chairwoman
uh a through c are all clearly
delineated um but we would want to
confirm
um the intent of d and and if that needs
this is saying it doesn't identify oh it
identifies the attorney general's office
as the chairperson
[Music]
and then it goes on to
talk about the other people so
it would be basically up to the
chairperson
to decide who these four members from
the
um leak
commission r does that how is that
wrong or right or uh
if i could just confirm uh and then
report back to madame chairman i would
appreciate just an opportunity to make
sure i don't speak out of turn
um it doesn't specifically say in hb2
that might be something we want to
further clarify
um through an amendment just to ensure
that who has the power to appoint those
individuals
okay nobody's jumping out there saying
i'm in charge so that's a good thing
okay just yeah that would
i think that is um is necessary
since the commission is just
being formed and these four other
members
wherever they're going to come from i
don't know
i'm gonna turn to the money
okay i went and got my
anyhow
it shows uh five people
for this future whatever it is
and i'm trying to come to grips
with what kinds of people
would you be looking for to run
so representative what i would say is
ultimately all of this is contingent on
what the study commission has for
recommendations
as for the structure that we
built the budget around and again all of
this is subject to change
this would have an unclassified director
and associate director and then there
would be three classified positions that
you see in hb1
uh an attorney two a paralegal two
and a clerk three so it really is just
the bare bones of what an
entity like this would be required to
have to conduct these types of
proceedings
we chose very detailed analysis the
alternative could have been just to
appropriate say half a million dollars
without thinking through what the actual
structure would be
um so we went through a more thorough
exercise
but all of this is with the caveat that
whatever structure this commission would
recommend
and the legislature would then have to
pass and adopt
that would be what that ultimately would
happen but we wanted to make sure we had
a rough outline of how much money would
be required for an entity like this to
exist
if i could just follow up a little bit
then i'll be right with you mary
just the page that's all i need oh sorry
page 132.
um do we have
other things like this in state
government
that have a permanent uh
people assigned to them assigned to it
uh so madam chairman on that point i
would say that there are
several agencies that would have
some relation to what this new entity
would be
tasked with i think you have most of
them here on the call
uh this afternoon as well um but
the recommendation from lee act was an
independent
uh statewide entity which is why we're
moving in this direction
um and i guess that's all that i would
have to say on that
topic but i think this might be another
area for the study commission to review
um exactly what existing functions uh
potentially overlap with this
but again ultimately we want to put that
for the study commission to report back
on
uh and from there i'd turn it over to
yeah i think the closest model that we
have uh that's currently in state
government to the current
version of of of what we um
have put together would be the human
rights commission
which has a pretty small uh permanent
staff but
there's there's commission members that
that oversee it and that's kind of the
setup
that we are going with in the new
senator p thank you um
madam chair i don't know who would
answer this probably the um
attorney general matthew um what is the
final authority
of this commission or is that to be
the authority of the commission or of
the underlying agency that the
well as they make their determinations
about the process
after the process is determined will
they
implementation
so as it's currently written and this is
section 146
of hb2 at the bottom of page 64.
the study commission is repealed on
november 2nd of 2021
so as currently written contemplated
they would not
continue to exist because again their
duty is to bring forward legislation
if there's another model you know i
think we're open to it but we tried to
hue very closely to what the lea
commission
uh early yeah what liax put forward as
their recommendation
um and given that we weren't able to
quite solidify all those details in time
for the filing deadline
um we've continued on with the study
commission but again
in a very short window just to finalize
those details
all right thank you representative heath
i would say that
this commission might in fact recommend
an oversight commission but that's up to
whatever whatever the commission decides
it's kind of a open-ended
you know because there there are people
that oversee the
if you're using the human rights
commission there are people that do
oversee that as well
so we'll i guess we'll uh we'll wait and
see what happens
thank you madam chair just a little
thought here what if this
group comes up with a you know
recommending future
legislation and either the legislation
does not get filed or does not get
passed
where are we then just a little thought
well we're right where we are now
exactly
with mr uh mr scipio taking care of all
of it
so uh i think that uh
there are folks on here or you know
maybe
let me just let me just throw this out
too
it could be that instead of creating a
whole new commission
they just give a different sort of
authority
to what the folks and police standards
and training do
i mean they don't have to have a new
commission you know it could
it could be that that's where this whole
thing
lands but that's a i guess what i'm
saying is that that's a
discussion and decision that we don't
need to make
um that's what we have the commission
uh representative turcotte did you have
i thought i'd seen your hand up earlier
did i miss it you did but uh
somewhere along the line somebody
answered it so i'm all set
the money in 2023
not because i don't think that if
whatever is devised
is we'll need people okay
but we have already in the
hb1 set
the scope of
what this new thing can do
by assigning by saying in here
that you can have five people
and so that bothers me
to the extent that
i'm not i'm just not sure that that's
the right way
to build this um this railroad
um myself
i would rather see us do something
like you know put a dollar in it and
then whatever the commission comes up
with
would be something that says
you know based on the fact that the uh
the law passes then the governor has the
authority to
withdraw the money at that point in time
that's just that's my thought process on
and representative or madam chairman
that certainly
could be one approach but what we
ultimately decided to do
was to err on the side of caution to
ensure that the budget that we pass
is balanced and has funding set
aside for this entity now if the
commission
either comes to no recommendation or
they recommend legislation that isn't
ultimately enacted the money would lapse
back to the general fund
at the end of the biennium um but we
wanted to make sure that
this didn't get lost in the budget
process and then
if there's not money sitting around next
year to fund it
we didn't want to hamstring their
efforts because the governor of course
is committed to
the leak recommendations and is
committed to bring them forward
and again we just wanted to make sure
there was a pot of money
for them i would defer to the lba if if
there's a different model to just do a
line item appropriation
that a new entity could assign to
different class lines or whatnot
again we did a very detailed sketch
but didn't want to constrain what this
i hear you what's the difference between
looking at what i have in the budget
versus
versus what the governor had in his
budget but uh
you know i i understand where you're
coming from
and i also realize that it will um
it will take some time to stand up this
group
it's not it's not like it's going to
occur
however it is however it is set up
so um we'll we'll think about that
and we'll we'll work on that as a
committee
but that's just my initial initial
thought process
um
okay are there any other comments
questions
thoughts anything anybody wants to say
oh
representative heath mine's just an
apology to
um mr skipper in case i
made it sound like i didn't think that
things were going the way they should be
going
i want to apologize it's totally my
ignorance of
how the whole system works i'm a little
bit embarrassed
madam there is absolutely no no
apology needed and candidly
unless you're a police officer or you're
involved with
with law enforcement in the state of new
hampshire nobody even knows we're here
so no worries at all
i'm sorry we know you were there okay
and uh some of us knew that you worked
on those issues
but um some of us didn't and that's okay
you've been doing as as good a job as
you could with your hands tied
so i we we all
no you have not you're relatively new
but
since you've been on you have been doing
doing a great job
so if there are no other
comments questions thoughts
okay we will uh this is just another
one on our list of things to resolve
between now and about next tuesday or
wednesday
we had something pretty difficult this
morning
i think this one is a little easier
if we can figure out the funding
side of it i don't think any of us are
opposed to the um the formation of the
commission
and for them to bring us legislation
next year
when um at that point um
finance will be out of it which is not a
bad thing
oh sorry and i don't think there's
anyone
on this uh this group that uh
wants to be part of um
part of this study commission so um
if there is i'm sure you can
contact mr broadhead and he would be
happy to uh
find a place for you so if there's
nothing
else uh mickey do you have anything to
add
no i i don't have anything to add um i
think at the very least
you know there was some co-mingling of
this um
commission and the body cam
dash cam fund in house bill 2. so it's a
little confusing as you read through
these sections
so at the very least we're going to
probably do an amendment to clean
clean up what's here and then also
incorporate whatever the division's
recommendations are but i just want to
make it
clear that uh there if you're confused
when you look through these sections i
think there was some
some issues with the drafting so but
we'll work through it
well mickey i think we had a lot of
confusion on a lot of things so
but that's but that's why we're here
that's why you're here is to uh
is to uh make sure that you uh you keep
us straight
but i agree totally that uh
this commission stuck in there where it
was probably
oh i'm sorry represent heath ma'am could
we just walk through this week
i know we have a lot to cover um
and um i know that tomorrow we've got
two
bills and then we have a hearing all
forever
then on wednesday we're going to have a
work session now will that go
late into the just i'm trying to figure
out my calendar for the week of
of how extensive we're going to be tied
up in the afternoons and mornings
how about it depends um
mickey is uh putting together for
everybody a list of
what we know as open items
okay and um i will go through that list
tomorrow no probably not tomorrow but
wednesday
that we will start down that list of
things to do
and um i will try to
initially pick out the things that i
think
we are all in agreement on and then
um kind of leave the uh
stickier things um
for later on like i know
for example we don't all agree on
the combining of the university and the
community college so
that will be you know a longer
discussion but
that's that's kind of what my approach
is
and that's why i mentioned that um
you know if you have amendments that you
want to bring in
to hb2 that you that you do that
uh so that we know you know
ahead of time if that's the right term
where
these um where these discussions are
going to go
okay so representative murray you have a
question
yes thank you do we know what our
allotment is yet and as ways and means
the first the answer to your first
question is no
the answer to your second question is
yes
when when we will get that i have no
idea
okay uh but um
i'm not expecting um
tens of millions of dollars i'll put it
that way that
uh just so it goes in the right
direction from ours perspective
i i got that i got that uh but i'm not
on ways and means okay
so i have i have done my darndest
to uh get them to uh
up that because it's you know it's
really the general fund is
is uh is where
the majority of the problem is and uh
and as we know our share of general
funds is
pretty small in relationship to division
one and division three
so um we'll just have to see how that
all
all plays out but i don't expect that
we'll be hearing anything from ways and
maybe the first part of next week and
and i'm sure at that time that
more than likely any extra general funds
would go to one and two
or one in three okay that's just my
that's my supposition okay
representative porter thank you madam
chair
seeing as how this sitting with all of
you has been enjoyable and informative
it's also kind of
messed up my schedule i just need to
know are we meeting on friday
no we are not meeting on friday friday
i'm meeting with the fiscal committee
okay so we are meeting tuesday wednesday
thursday this week and then monday again
next week
and tuesday that's the plan and
wednesday
and thursday it depends on how how fast
we get our work done
if we get it done if we're all in
agreement on
all these issues we should be finished
by friday by thursday
but i know that that's a pipe dream on
my part
thank you madam chair is there
uh anything else oh but by the way as
long as i still have uh
safety here um
i never got anything back from
any of the committees on the radio
what was that called radio make sure
everybody's
the same part of it
language yeah
um when you say anything from anybody
who is the anyone ma'am
i think i who did we send that to mickey
uh does it turn up to science and
technology perhaps
i can't remember i know you sent it to
one of the policy committees for review
yeah i i i'm not sure which one i sent
it to but
i think i sent it to transportation
maybe they were the wrong ones but they
didn't get back to me either
so i guess that um
there's nothing in there that is
controversial
that i could see is there well
i i won't say i what i will say is i ask
director doyle mark
doyle to kind of speak to the other uh
stakeholders the other commissioners
and uh you know have some conversations
of what
it's you know what is the vision here
with this you know it's
basically for planning making sure we're
making interoperable
decisions on purchases and somewhat like
of an overarching
governance like doit has for certain
expenditures so
we have heard nothing back um so
that's and i and i asked director doyle
personally you know have you
spoken outside there to the other
agencies and he's very
um uh he he over communicates
uh so i haven't heard anything man
negative okay
well that's easy then we'll uh
we'll just leave it unless someone uh
unless somebody comes and um
gets all upset but i certainly haven't
heard anything
steve anything to add to that steve
uh no uh just everything that you said
uh is absolutely true we haven't heard
any any real negative
okay that sounds wonderful
all right so we will see you all
tomorrow morning
keep smiling thank you bye